officials in afghanistan say thousands
of people are in need of clean water and
food following a devastating earthquake
more than a thousand people were killed
in the quake in a remote part of the
country near the pakistani border our
correspondent zaman rasheed joins us now
from the afghan capital car ball uh so
insane are the taliban government
beginning to sound desperate
well look jonathan i think it's starting
to look like a case of be careful what
you wish for yes the taliban government
here are in charge
but i think also they're slowly
realizing that in fact they are
dangerously desperate why is that and
that's because they've been isolated
from the western world with a nine
billion dollar asset freeze they are
facing the worst drought in four decades
they are going through a hunger crisis
and of course they've got a terrible
track record when it comes to human
rights rowing back on pledges they made
when they came into power last year a
sticking point for western governments
and now of course this catastrophic
earthquake are reminded to them that
they may not have the infrastructure in
place to deal with such a disaster
yesterday we spoke to someone from the
foreign ministry he said that they do
have the infrastructure and in fact that
it was the efforts of the coalition of
the last 20 years which has ruined a lot
of things for them and today we spoke to
another very senior member of the
government one who's actually been at
the epicenter of this earthquake and he
recalled what he saw
almost
um
okay
now that's something you don't see every
day whether you have sympathy for them
or not a member of this organization one
which is often tough powerful and and
often quite intimidating breaking down
like that but i think there's probably a
sign there that they need to do
something in order to change and to make
sure that if they want help in the
future they get it and also if they want
a seat at the international table they
will need to change and compromise